hi Matt Welch here with nick gillespie
we're here on ask a libertarian day in
honor of the paperback publication of
the Declaration of Independence how
libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America next question comes
from case on white via email do you
believe there's a growing income gap if
so do you believe its problem and what
is the libertarian approach to fixing it
Nick yeah there is a growing amount of
inequality when you look at the very
richest and the very poorest that gap
has been widening in the United States
as it has through all developed
countries is it a problem I don't think
so in and of itself the real question is
income mobility what are the odds of one
person particularly those towards the
bottom of the distribution can move up
the distribution all of the data that is
relevant show that income mobility has
not decreased over the past 40 or so
years that's the real issue income
mobility not income inequality and I
always get upset when people confuse or
conflate those two things they're very
different things if we want more income
mobility and I do because I still have a
long way to go up and I want my kids
both to be able to go up or go down
based on how they act and the choices
that they make in their life I'm because
that's a better system for more people
when you can actually get the rewards to
your benefits the way we do that is by
minimizing government by streamlining
the ways in which people can find their
way in the world and instead of trying
to rig the game so that certain types of
people get a leg up for doing certain
types of activities let's flatten it out
a bit more the most unequal societies
I've ever seen are those that are
currently or recently communist everyone
is supposed to be equal but the gnomon
clap Torah above it all has perks that
everybody else can't even dream of I
don't think equality ultimately is the
goal equality of opportunity is the best
that we can shoot towards that is Matt
Welch talking about ask a libertarian
day 2012 we will be here all day and
we'll be taking your questions thanks